so we have a bunch of numbers listed up
here and my goal in this video is to see
if we can classify them into different
types of number categories and let me
draw the categories so this circle over
here this we can this represents all of
the numbers that can be represented as
the fraction of two integers and of
course the denominator can't be equal to
zero because we don't know what it means
to put a zero in the denominator so
let's call these or the standard way of
calling these things these things that
can be represented as a fraction of two
integers we call these rational numbers
rational numbers and if something cannot
be represented as the fraction as a
fraction of two integers we call
irrational numbers irrational numbers
irrational numbers and the size of these
circles don't show how large these sets
are there is actually an infinite number
of rational and an infinite number of
irrational numbers so these are the
irrational numbers irrational so these
cannot be represented as a fraction of
two integers and then within rational
numbers you have integers themselves so
I'll do that in do that in this blue
color integers so integers are numbers
that don't have to be represented as a
fraction or a decimal so these are
integers right over here integers and
then a subset of integers are whole
numbers so if you essentially say the
non-negative integers you're then
talking about whole numbers so let me do
that subset right over here so these are
going to be the whole numbers so whole
whole numbers whole whole numbers right
over here and actually let me just label
it all these are rational we've done
that same color rational numbers and of
course irrational numbers irrational
numbers irrational numbers an integer
well if I could say literally that is an
integer let's think about the integers
but I would say let's just think about
rationally let's talk about the rational
numbers all right now that we have these
categories in place let's categorize
them and like always pause the video see
if you can figure out what category
these numbers are fall into where would
you put them on this on this diagram so
let's start off with three this is
positive three it can be definitely
represented as a fraction you can
represent it as three over one but it
doesn't have to be represented as a
fraction a little rate could be just a
three right over there but it's also
non-negative so three is a whole number
so three maybe I'll do it in the color
of the category so three three is a
whole number so it's a member of that
set but if you're a whole number you're
also an integer and you're also a
rational number so three is a whole
number it's an integer and it's a
rational number now let's think about
negative five now negative five once
again it can be represented as a
fraction but it doesn't have to be but
it is negative so it's not going to be a
whole number so negative five is going
to sit right over here it's an integer
and if you're an integer you're
definitely going to be a rational number
but it's not a whole number because it
is negative now we have now we have 0.25
well this for sure can be represented as
a fraction this is twenty five
hundredths right over here so we can
represent that as a fraction of two
integers I should say it's twenty-five
hundredths but there's no way to
represent this except using a fraction
of two integers so 0.25 is a rational
number but it's not an integer and not a
whole number
now what about 22 over 7 well here it's
clearly represented already as a
fraction of two integers but I don't
think I can represent this any other
except as a fraction of two integers I
can't somehow make this without using a
fraction or some type of decimal that
that may that might repeat so this right
over here this would also be a rational
rational number but it's also it's not
an integer not a whole number
now this over here zero point two seven
one
0.271 three then the one three repeats
this is anything 0.271 three one three
one three that's what that line up there
represents now you might not realize it
yet but any number that repeats
eventually this one does repeat
eventually you have the point 1 3 1
through order you have the zero point
two seven one three one three one three
any number like this can be represented
as a fraction for example and I'm going
to do it here just for the sake of time
but for example zero point three
repeating that's the same thing as 1/3
it later on we're going to see
techniques of how do you convert this to
a fraction of two integers but for our
sake we just know that this can be
represented as a fraction of two
integers just the way that zero point
three repeating can be and so we would
put this under rational numbers zero
point two seven one three repeating but
you have to represent it as a either as
a decimal or a fraction of integers you
if if you didn't have to then it could
have been an integer but we're it up
there in rational numbers now the square
root of 10 square root of 10 this is
interesting so any square root of a
non-perfect square is going to be
irrational so this is going to be
irrational I'm not proving it to you
here but you cannot represent this as
the ratio of two integers or a fraction
of with two integers with an integer in
the numerator integer denominator you
this will be if you were to represent it
as a decimal it will not repeat it'll
just keep being new new digits it will
not repeat over time so this right over
here is an irrational number it's not
rational it cannot be represented as the
ratio of two integers all right fourteen
over seven this is the ratio of two
integers four so this for sure is
rational but if you think about it 14
over seven that's another way of saying
fourteen over seven is the same thing as
two these two things are equivalent so
fourteen over seven is the same thing as
two so this is actually a whole number
it doesn't look like a whole number the
remember a whole number is a
non-negative number that doesn't need to
be represented as the ratio of two
integers and this one even though we did
representative Rachel tutors it doesn't
need to be represented as the ratio of
two integers you could represent this as
just two so that's going to be a whole
number fourteen over seven which is the
same thing as two that is a whole number
now two pi now pi is an irrational pi is
an irrational number so if we just take
a multiple of Pi if we just take a an
integer multiple of Pi like that this is
also going to be an irrational number
it's if you looked at its decimal
representation it will never repeat so
that's two pi right over there now what
about let me do that same since I've
been consistent relatively consistent
with the colors so this is two pi right
over there now what about the negative
square root of 25 well 25 is a perfect
square square root of that's it's going
to be five so this thing is going to be
this thing is going to be equivalent to
negative five so this is just another
representation of this right over here
so it is an integer it's not a whole
number because it's negative but it's an
integer negative square root of 25 these
two things are actually these two things
are actually the same number just
different ways of representing them and
then you have a t of the square root of
nine over square root of nine over seven
well what's the principal root of nine
this thing is going to be the same thing
this thing is the same let me just in a
different color this is this is the same
thing as square root of nine is three
it's the principal root of 9 so it's
three sevenths so this is a ratio of two
integers this is a rational number
square root of nine over seven is the
same thing as three sevens now let me
just give you one more just for the road
what about pi over pi
what is that going to be well pi divided
by pi is going to be equal to one so
this is actually a whole number so I
could write pi over pi right over there
that's just a very fancy way of saying
one